what we will introduce ourselves to in
this video is the notion of electric
circuits and ohm's law which you can
view as the most fundamental law or the
most basic law or simplest law when we
are dealing with circuits and it
connects the ideas of voltage
which we will get more of a intuitive
idea for in a second and current
which is denoted by capital letter i i
guess to avoid confusion if they used a
capital c with the coulomb
and what connects these two is the
notion of a resistance
resistance
that is denoted with the capital letter
r
and just to cut to the chase the
relationship between these is a pretty
simple mathematical one it is that
voltage is equal to
current
times resistance
or another way to view it if you divide
both sides by resistance you get that
current
is equal to voltage divided by
resistance voltage divided by
resistance
but intuitively what is voltage what is
current and what is resistance and what
are the units for them so that we can
make sense of this
so to get an intuition for what these
things are and how they relate let's
build a metaphor using the flow of water
which isn't a perfect metaphor but it
helps me at least understand the
relationship between voltage current and
resistance so let's say i have this
vertical pipe of water it's closed at
the bottom right now and it's all full
of water there's water above here
as well
so the water in the pipe
so let's say the water right over here
it's going to have some potential energy
and this potential energy as we will see
it is analogous to voltage voltage
is electric potential
electric
potential
now it isn't straight up potential
energy it's actually potential energy
per unit charge so let me write that
potential energy
per
unit
unit charge you could think of it as
joules which is potential energy or
units of energy per coulomb that is our
unit charge and the unit for voltage in
general is
volts
now let's think about what would happen
if we now open the bottom of this pipe
so we open this up
what's going to happen well the water is
immediately just going to drop straight
down that potential energy is going to
be converted to kinetic energy
and you could look at a certain part of
the pipe right over here right over here
and you could say well how much water is
flowing per unit time
and that amount of water that is flowing
through the pipe at that point in a
specific amount of time that is
analogous to current current is the
amount of charge so we could say charge
per unit time q for charge
and t
for
time
and intuitively you could say how much
how
much
charge
flowing
flowing past
a point in a circuit a
point in
circuit
in
a let's say a unit of time we could use
think of it as a second and so you could
also think about it as coulombs per
second charge per unit time and the idea
of resistance is something could just
keep that charge from flowing at an
arbitrarily high rate and if we want to
go back to our water metaphor what we
could do is we could introduce something
that would impede the water and that
could be a narrowing of the pipe and
that narrowing of the pipe would be
analogous to resistance
so in this situation once again i have
my vertical water pipe i've opened it up
and you still would have that potential
energy which is analogous to voltage and
it would be converted to kinetic energy
and you would have a flow of water
through that pipe
but now at every point in this pipe the
amount of water that's flowing past at a
given moment of time is going to be
lower because you have literally this
bottleneck right over here so this
narrowing is analogous to resistance how
much
charge
flow
impeded
impeded and the unit here is the ohm
is the ohm which is denoted with the
greek letter omega
so now that we've defined these things
and we have our metaphor let's actually
look at an electric circuit so first let
me ha construct a battery
so this is my
battery and the convention is my
negative terminal has is the shorter
line here so i can say that's the
negative terminal that is the positive
terminal associated with that battery i
could have some voltage and just to make
this tangible let's say the voltage
is equal to 16 volts across this battery
and so one way to think about it is the
potential energy per unit charge let's
say we have electrons here at the
negative terminal the potential energy
per coulomb here is 16 volts these
electrons if they have a path would go
to the positive terminal and so we can
provide a path
so let me draw it like this and at first
i'm going to not make the path available
to the electrons i'm going to have an
open
circuit here
but i'm going to make this path for the
electrons and so as long as our circuit
is open like this this is actually
analogous to the closed pipe the
electrons there's no way for them to get
to the positive terminal but if we were
to close the circuit right over here if
we were to close it then all of a sudden
the electrons could begin to flow
through this circuit in an analogous way
to the way that the water would flow
down this pipe
now when you see a schematic diagram
like this when you just see these lines
those usually denote something that has
no resistance but that's very
theoretical in practice even a very
simple wire that's a good conductor
would have some resistance and the way
that we denote resistance is with a
jagged line
and so let me draw resistance here
so that is how we denote it in a circuit
diagram and let's say the resistance
here is 8 ohms
so my question to you is given the
voltage and given the resistance what
will be the current through this circuit
what is the rate at which charge will
flow past a point in this circuit
pause this video and try to figure it
out
well to answer that question you just
have to go to ohm's law we want to solve
for current we know the voltage we know
the resistance
so the current in this example
is going to be our voltage which is 16
volts
divided by our resistance which is 8
ohms
and so this is going to be 16 divided by
8 is equal to two
and the units for our current which is
charge per unit time coulombs per second
you could say two coulombs per second or
you could say amperes and we can denote
amperes with a capital a we talked about
these electrons flowing and you're going
to have two coulombs worth of electrons
flowing per second past any point on
this circuit and it's true at any point
same reason that we saw over here even
though it's wider up here and it's
narrower here because of this bottleneck
the same amount of water that flows
through this part of the pipe in a
second would have to be the same amount
that flows through that part of the pipe
in a second and that's why for this
circuit for this very simple circuit the
current that you would measure at that
point this point and this point would
all be the same
but there's a quirk
pause this video and think about what do
you think would be the direction for the
current
well if you knew about electrons and
what was going on you would say well the
electrons are flowing in this direction
and so for this electric current i would
say that it was flowing in i would
denote the current going like that
well it turns out that the convention we
use is the opposite of that and that's
really a historical quirk when benjamin
franklin was first studying circuits
he did not know about electrons they
would be discovered roughly 150 years
later he just knew that what he was
labeling as charge and he arbitrarily
labeled positive and negative he just
knew they were opposites he knew
something like charge was flowing and so
in his studies of electricity
he denoted current as going from the
positive to the negative terminal and so
we still use that convention today even
though that is the opposite of the
direction of the flow of electrons and
as we will see later on current doesn't
always involve electrons
and so this current here is going to be
a 2
ampere current